welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and obi-wan kenobi's six episodes
explored how the exile jedi master
continues to kick himself over the ways
he failed anakin skywalker from
abandoning him on the lava beach of
mustafar to humiliating him with an
empty freighter switcheroo on jabim but
as riva and owen lars have suggested how
much of the blame for everything awful
in the galaxy really rests on ob1 really
i think this series is inviting us to
victim blame here so in this final
episode of our star wars miniseries
between the duels let us ask the
question how much of this was obi-wan's
fault obi-wan himself indicated that he
was taking some responsibility for
anakin's dark turn as far back as
revenge of the sith i have failed you
anakin now he didn't go into further
detail but contained in those words were
volumes of context for the ways obi-wan
failed to see the darkness rising in
anakin his denial of anakin's ambitions
and his passions and his needs for
paternal guidance and obi-wan's overall
blindness to the sith plot to erode the
republic and wipe out the jedi kenobi
episode 5 returns to obi-wan's early
tutelage of anakin sometime shortly
before attacking the clones when anakin
gained the upper hand during a safari
session until obi-wan used an arguably
sneaky sucker move of snatching a saber
from anakin's hand making us wonder why
haven't jedi been doing that all the
time but then leaving him with this
nugget of wisdom you're a great warrior
anakin but you'll need to prove yourself
as your undoing until you overcome it
a padawan will still be uh padawan you
will still be who does this syntax
inverter think he is yoda obviously not
because this wisdom is nowhere near the
level of the greatest teacher
failure is we are
what they grow beyond
that is the true burden of all masters
by the way this is my favorite piece of
yoda wisdom and if it doesn't speak to
you just give yourself time because if
you've ever been a teacher or a mentor
or a parent or an older sibling damn
does it hit hard now we can't really
blame obi-wan for being not as good of a
teacher as yoda i mean no one is however
we can blame obi-wan for holding back
anakin in this rank of padawan denying
him jedi knight despite his ability to
beat his ass as decision might have even
been a test to become a jedi knight
simply because anakin is just eager to
prove himself that's a total double
standard considering 10 years earlier
obi-wan displayed the same kind of ego
and hot-headedness when he's dueling
darth maul on naboo what was his rage
fueled one-on-one with maul if not a
desperate need to slay his nemesis and
prove himself to his dying master and
how did yoda reward obi-wan for that
confer on you the level of jedi knight
the council does
huh how the turntables have
this denial of anakin's advancement was
a mistake as just giving the kid the
promotion he deserved may have replaced
that chip on his shoulder with instead
something his ego really needed the
heavy burden of responsibility because
nothing tempers the starvation of
ambition like the weight of office
sitting in one of the chairs of the jedi
council gives one all kinds of sobering
wisdom qui-gon jinn didn't want to sit
on that council for that reason obi-wan
only joined it when diva billabo was
like god no thanks i'm done now of
course the denial of anakin's
advancement wasn't specific to obi-wan
yoda and mace windu were even more
reluctant to bring anakin into the fold
and ultimately that distress was going
to be manipulated by palpatine anyway
yet still as a jedi master on this
council obi-wan should have like the
rest of them seeing all the red flags
that they were all being manipulated
into a political war at the start of
attack of the clones mace windu said
we're keepers of the peace not soldiers
which is hilarious when you look at how
quickly the jedi joined the war effort
leading the charge and for the years
that followed commanding clone troopers
under the rank of general peacekeepers
can't be generals now before you say it
wasn't just obi-wan who assumed the rank
of general well sure but it was obi-wan
alone an attack of the clones who
investigated sifo diaz's secret plot to
conspire with the kaminoans to raise an
army of clones a plot so sus that
someone acid washed star maps from the
jedi archives like if that the new red
flag for obi-wan what could be i mean
nothing against wrecks of the other
beloved clone troopers we got to know
throughout clone wars but obi-wan saw
how the sausage got made there and he
still gobbled it down and asked for
seconds and then at the height of the
clone wars obi-wan was so proud of being
a military general that he snapped back
at anakin who is defending tarkin that
jedi peacekeepers have no place on the
front line captain tarkin feels the jedi
should be
relieved from the burden of leading the
war effort that's ridiculous
maybe
but we aren't soldiers we're
peacekeepers
the jedi code often prevents us from
going far enough to achieve victory
a rather simple point of view
either way
he is a good captain shut up kenobi even
if tarkin is a dick i think we can all
agree there ya boy is speaking truth get
out of this war while you still can and
by the way this is what i love about
clone wars it's just so good about
blurring the lines and showing
subjective confusion of these characters
and now in this kenobi series riva as a
past young lean attacked in the jedi
temple on the night of border 66 dropped
all the blame at the feet of kenobi
where were you
while he was killing my friends
he was your padawan why didn't you stop
him why didn't you save us and obi-wan
is speechless he could try to answer
well i was on utapau i was betrayed by
commander cody i was fighting for my
life and by the time i rushed back to
the temple it was too late but he knows
if he were to say that the next words
out of her mouth would be well why
didn't you see it coming why were you
even honored about to begin with why did
you let yourself get drawn into this
pointless war while leaving your most
sacred mission the children completely
unprotected unprotected against the
fallen jedi that you brought into the
temple kenobi would have no answer to
that anyhow you'll remember this is the
same kind of shame that owen thrust on
him back in episode one when the time
comes he must be trained like you
trained his father
now to be fair to obi-wan because we've
been very unfair to him in this video
the guy was just doing his best to carry
out qui-gon's dying wish and to that
point it is worth considering what would
have happened to anakin if qui-gon
didn't die would anakin have turned to
the dark side in that scenario would
qui-gon's rogue attitude of defying the
council and his trust in the living
force as more of a grey jedi have been
more of a balanced mentorship for a
student like anakin than the dogmatic
haughtiness of obi-wan maybe definitely
something for obi-wan and qui-gon's
force ghost to stew over a bowl of
instastu and as this kenobi series
paired obi-wan with leia his memories of
her mother padme have gotten a big focus
in these episodes obi-wan knows that
anakin and padme's love affair was a
huge reason anakin broke from the jedi
since the jedi of course has that rule
against any romantic attachments however
clone wars revealed to us how obi-wan
definitely could have better mentored
his padawan on how a jedi should balance
one's love life and whether the jedi
order is ultimately worth it because our
man kenobi was totally in love with
duchess satine had you said the word
i would have left the jedi order yes it
wasn't obi-wan's puritanical commitment
to the jedi order that kept him from
satine the guy was waiting for sateen to
ask him to and then in clone wars season
7 obi-wan confirms that he knew about
anakin and padme i hope you at least
told padme i said hello he should have
let the boy love even the catholic
church has admitted its own celibacy vow
may have contributed to its history of
sex abuse and cover-ups when society
stigmatize sex and force love into the
shadows bad things happen so now as
obi-wan looks into the eyes of the love
children of that doomed romance and
tells leia he wishes he were her father
it's not him saying he wishes he was
with padme it's him saying that he
wishes leia had a different father and
it's him wishing he could have had a
daughter like her with his own lost love
sateen and again we are totally blaming
the victim here he's a fictional
character get over it and obi-wan
himself has admitted the error of his
ways from the first episode the fight is
done
we lost and let's be clear the real
villain of all this absolutely palpatine
and everyone else are just victims of
palpatine victimizing each other and
what i have loved about this obi-wan
kenobi series and the reason all heroes
are so beloved are their mistakes their
blindness their hypocrisy and then the
way they struggle to forgive themselves
and seek redemption and that is what we
connect with folks and that is why i
have so loved living inside the mind of
obi-wan kenobi and his guilt and his
fear and his renewed hope in this era
between the duels and i want to thank
you so much for joining us on this mini
series i love digging deeper into
obi-wan's journey with you all follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
do
[Music]